[Music]
hey everybody how are you
so Joker I've seen it twice now and and
and and I have some mixed feelings about
the Joker
okay so first good things I think it
looked amazing that seems a little
disingenuous I know that whole idea of
so what you think about this all the
lighting was good no I think the these
sort of recreation of ultimately in New
York I mean it's Gotham yes I know but
New York in the 1970s is pretty strong
you know the texture but the mood the
cinematography is great the sound design
is great all of the set decoration and
set dressing is is pretty phenomenal i I
think that Joaquin Phoenix is terrific
I mean it's he he's doing things my
favorite is when you see him start to
have that kind of nervous tic laughs and
his eyes are crying but he's laughing
and he's doing both at the same time and
it's a it's it's kind of it's gorgeous
and and like there's a lot of interior
work that he's doing there's a lot of
performative work that he's doing the
weight loss I mean that's always
impressive even if it doesn't really add
like a ton to performance per se but
it's he's building this character of
author Fleck and it's and it's it's
pretty impressive to see I think that
when you know the awards nomination
starts coming out he's going to get a
bowl of them there's absolutely a chance
in which he has a decent shot of that
he's gonna win or he could win would not
be mad at it if it happened so there
there is there is a decent amount to
recommend about this movie but in my in
my gut in my core I sort of walked out
or seen it twice now I saw it once
of same time with my son and and it's a
little hollow in a way you know like
it's it seems as if Joaquin and you know
co-writer director Todd Phillips are
doing like a cover performance of a song
that's been covered three or four times
before them and like they're doing a
cover of a cover and they don't quite
get the original if you if you catch my
meaning it's a little hollow in the
center and I noticed it for the first
time when the Joker and I'm not gonna
get like super heavy crazy spoilery
about it but if you've if you've seen a
trailer for this movie you know anything
about this movie you know that there's a
moment where the Joker commits a crime
right like it's at anus it's probably
murder
I had to definitely murder but he
commits this crime I mean the first time
he crosses that threshold he you know
he's running away through the streets
and he's a little panicked and weird and
and then he runs into a bathroom and
catches his breath and then starts to
dance and the dance is like like
haunting and evocative and super weird
and and languid and his arms are doing
odd things and his feet as this like
ballet meets Mummenschanz maids ax I
don't know what but I didn't know why he
did that I couldn't figure out why this
character after having done such a
heinous thing this side of the dance was
his reaction to it I just couldn't
figure it out and and the movie never
actually tells you why he did that
because Arthur Fleck in this film is
like a litany of things that have
happened to arthur Fleck and I couldn't
tell if that murder and the subsequent
revelations and and and and stuff he
learns about his family there's origin
and what-have-you if they are twisting
or Fleck into something else
or sort of chipping away at a and a and
a sort of barnacled like layer of life
and and circumstance and mannerisms and
manners that he'd built over the course
of a life if his chipping away then and
revealing something and I don't think
the movie knew which one that was
supposed to be and it and I just
couldn't find my way in to the film
itself because it seems as if the film
itself didn't really have a perspective
on this character and not to say that
the film has to judge its main character
I think there are plenty of movies about
heinous and awful human beings and/or
creatures that can behold them without
judging them but to a certain degree the
movie of the really says to have a
perspective on that character I put a
view of that character and it seems as
if to me the the great success of Joker
is the joaquin phoenix performance and
the great failure of joker is that all
it is is a joaquin phoenix performance
the script doesn't seem to support very
much of what he's doing to the point
where I mean Todd Phillips would even
say in interviews that we would just
like lock the camera down what King
would do stuff and we would have to hope
we could catch it which feels odd to me
that that as a story and as a
storyteller you would see them that much
authority over the story to that lead
actor even if he's doing amazing stuff
even if he's doing phenomenal work it
seems as if it needs to be phenomenal
work in service of something and I
couldn't figure out what the performance
wasn't service out I was most sort of in
with the movie when it had these little
glancing blows with Batman lore as we
know it or don't know it again I'm not
gonna spoil too much of it except I will
say that and it's barely it's not even
spoiler but I will say that there is a
movie playing at a movie theater at the
very end of this movie that is both
exactly what you think you know about
the Batman origin and a glorious tweek
uh-huh it seems as if they set this
movie in 1979
just so that this is the movie that
could've been playing at the theater and
I love it because it's one of my
favorite movies ever made so you know
III I appreciate the movie more than I
like the movie
I admire the things that was trying to
go for more than I'm satisfied by where
it went it and it's it's and I don't
think it quite you know and I spoke
about around on that fat man beyond when
we first talked about the reviews and
the awards hype and and the beginning of
the you know two or three weeks before
jerky came out there was concerned about
the responsibility of the movie to both
itself into the audience is gonna see it
I still think you know for as little
perspective and judgment that the movie
has about its main character I think it
does to a certain degree
see itself as Arthur flex story about
himself and he sees himself as a hero
and so the movie consequently because
there's nothing else besides a
performance also sees arthur fleck of
the hero which is a little you know
troubling to me but it's not
it is actionable in that way because
Arthur Fleck there isn't very much there
besides that performance and maybe
that's my design
I don't know I mean I remember seeing
the the Twilight movies never at the
books but I saw the movies because you
know I I was an entertainment journalist
and it was the biggest story in
entertainment for a good long while and
I felt like I need to know what this is
about it's the job and I started I'm
like what is with this girl is girlish
so boring she's a mope like why are
these vampires and whale was interested
in her like sure there's nothing going
on there and it then became clear that
that was by design
that character so boring so that every
you know sort of post-pubescent woman in
the audience or reading the books or
their moms could imagine themselves as
that character or I am more interesting
than Bella is so why not me
I'm just as worthy as she is
so I'm wondering if that the the lack of
definition of Arthur Fleck
is by design making it to the audience
can impose themselves and imprint
themselves upon that character because
he is such a cipher so that's a little
troubling
the film has this weird tick tick it's
an obsession with using black women as
avatars of social failure that every
time Arthur Fleck is looking for support
every time she's he's looking for help
every time he's looking for for somebody
to help guide him through this world he
turns to a woman of color who ultimately
says no which is weird
you know I don't know if that's a thing
that Todd Phillips recognizes in the
movie I don't know if that's a thing
that he wanted to put in the movie by
design I don't know if it was like hey
we we need to diversify this cast and so
let's just cast all of these characters
of color which you know on the one hand
is cool but on the other hand is also
irresponsible in that maybe he didn't
know what those characters were saying
about the world or how the movie was
referring to these characters and what
Arthur flex judgment on these these
women are it's you know it's just weird
I don't understand it but I don't know
if the movie understands it either it
could have been from a perfectly
well-meaning place that just when you
watch it it begins to you know the
isolated occurrences begin to at some
point add up to a picture that seems a
little bit less than than equitable and
to those characters you know like and I
think the there's always going to be a
desire and attempt to on a joke a movie
figure out how it lines up with the
other narratives that we know like where
it slots in into the Batman story where
it you know where it's true or not true
real or not
does it obey any semblance of continuity
this one kind of doesn't seem to
although you know Joaquin and Todd said
hey we like to make more of these and I
don't know how that lines up people have
said and I think Gotham did this also
which is the Joker that you meet is not
the Joker that we know it is some like
proto Joker that the Joker that we would
eventually see the Joker that actually
goes mano a mano with Batman would be
inspired by this first character I don't
know I'm not sure I mean I I applaud I
applaud the efforts of this movie to
want to be its own thing given that
we've seen we've gone down the road a
little bit with DC trying to tie
everything together and it seems they
were far more successful when they're
not trying to do that and so yeah man I
mean do your own thing be your own thing
but don't be afraid that you're a comic
book movie don't be afraid to embrace
your your origins if comic book fans are
about anything it's about origin so if
this movie doesn't exist unless it's
about an origin so so yeah I mean I I
have feelings about it to be to be sure
in it and I think I've talked about some
of them I think maybe later on we'll
dive a little bit deeper into like
actual plot stuff and things that I
doing things that I don't dig but I
think for a spoiler-free review and if
there's still people out there who
hasn't seen it because this thing is is
a bit of a Titan at the box office it is
it is a mix bad for me it is not it is
not at all a horror show in a bad way
it's not at all hard show in a good way
it it kind of walks between those lines
for me I've had to give it a letter
grade it's kind of probably like a
b-minus I think um because the greatness
of that performance is somewhat
diminished I think by the by the
lackluster sort of lack of enthusiasm of
the script of the actual narrative of
the actual story
and it's it's it's somewhat refusing to
want to stick a landing even though it
has like four or five of them but yeah
you know I mean if you like it power to
you if you don't like it I understand
why these are all just opinions these
are all just you know every every time
you go into a movie you come away with
it with the way it made you feel and the
way it makes you feel is as valid as the
way it makes me feel as the is as valid
ease of mm as the way it makes anybody
else feel the only thing that that
differs is you know how you can
articulate that feeling and if other
people respond to that but you know
never let anybody say that your opinion
is invalid because that's not how
opinions work art is subjective and we
each of us come to it with different
things and you know the life that I've
led that has led me into that door to
watch that movie is different than the
life that you lived it led you through
that door to watch that movie so you
know if you da get power to you nobody
wants a bad movie if you didn't like it
just as good you know everybody wants a
better movie so so listen hit us up on
the on the Twitter's keV is gone for a
while he may pop in here and there was
real trying to work out whether or not
we can Skype him in from the road when
we do some some live black men on
Batman's
for now sorry black man beyond I guess
I've fallen into that trap but we've got
a couple coming up they should be a ton
of fun we'll have kept back in the
studio slash the bar in December and and
we will try and maintain some songs in
normalcy until he then goes back off on
tour but listen stay tuned
same fad time same fat channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
and we'll see you guys soon
all right yeah be good
[Music]
you